- [Ben] What is food?
Food is any nutritious substance
that people or animals eat or drink
or that plants absorb in order
to maintain life and growth.
My name is Ben Brown, and I'm a filmmaker,
working with Great Big Story.
I've always taken an
interest in nutrition.
But, over the last few years,
I've been asking myself:
what does food really mean to me?
Every day, we are confronted with endless,
conflicting information,
about what we should,
and should not be eating.
Sugar-free, low-fat, GMO,
MSG, naturally-added flavors.
As convenience in price
take priority over quality and health,
we find ourselves becoming disconnected
from the food that sustains us.
In search of some simple answers,
I traveled to Costa Rica,
to meet a farmer who abandoned
the fast pace city life,
to reconnect with food,
by growing it himself.
- [Henry] I'm Henry.
Henry Karczynski.
I'm manager of Villa Vanilla,
a organic, biodynamic spice farm.
I grow spices here, in the
central pacific of Costa Rica.
I started in Chicago.
I grew up in Chicago.
I had a couple jobs.
I remember getting in my car,
you know, I had to visit clients
on the north side of Chicago.
I would, like, go right to the drive-in,
get my Big Mac, and french
fries, and soft drink,
and then, head out on the
roads to my next contract.
I mean, I would do that when I was 24.
It was a rat race, and
everybody's trying to struggle
to get up the ladder.
And then, when they get
to the top, they go:
what did I do with my life?
You know, it's already too late.
And I had to, sort of, restart, look
at what am I gonna do,
and the little seed
started growing in me,
to actually do my own thing.
I just had something growing
in me, to grow, to grow plants,
to grow food, to do a farm.
And, I was introduced to
biodynamics, from the book,
the Secrets of the Soil.
I think the most impact that had,
was that it removed those blindfolds,
and I was able to see the big picture.
You know, in a way, a mission I have,
is to use the farm as
a, sort of, a message,
for people to look at, at food.
We are living on this planet,
and so, we're also here
to enjoy the pleasures
the food, the sensuality
of living on this planet.
Food is a flavor.
It's an aroma.
It's something to enjoy.
So, what I would actually recommend,
to people that are starting
that first journeys,
start a garden.
Grow your tomatoes, grow your lettuce.
Make that first step.
You'll be blown away on how much,
that how good that food tastes,
and you can be started,
connecting with Mother Earth.
The most important thing, is to get that,
take that first step.
As I said, at one time, I
was a little bit discouraged,
because of the environments.
But recently, there's optimism.
There's lights at that end of that tunnel.
- [Ben Voiceover] I share
Henry's optimism for change.
We already know about the
endless health benefits
of eating natural, organic produce.
But, I also believe that by improving
our relationship with food,
we can reconnect with
this beautiful planet.
To consume consciously, is to take action,
against the destructive objectives
of large-scale food production.
Mother Earth is a beautiful,
biological system.
So, we must keep it simple.
Take responsibility, and work to protect
the only home we have.
(gentle music)